le corbeau fier et orgueilleux était
perché sur un arbre
le renard rusé et flatteur voulu lui
prendre son fromage le corbeau et le
renard la poule aux oeufs d'or ou encore
le renard et la cigogne les Fables de La
Fontaine n'ont plus de secret pour
l'artiste peintre Lucas candle à travers
son exposition au musée Grataloup il
nous propose sa propre interprétation
des fables à travers une quinzaine de
toiles ça touche ce côté en paix de rêve
un peu imaginaire ça permet aux artistes
justement dans le domaine de la rampe et
fantastique de les interpréter chaque
artiste dans sa façon ce qui nous plaît
à ceux qui a justement même les
personnes qui connaissent les femmes
finalement ils se disent comme ça et
finalement je la vois tout petit peu
métamorphose qui est expose ici chef de
fil du mouvement réaliste magique en
France Lucas scandale propose une vision
réaliste du monde moderne en y ajoutant
des éléments magiques fantastiques et
surréalistes un tableau aussi qui est le
conseil tenu par les rats moi je les ai
suspendus dans l'espace donc la cloche
représente finalement ce qu'il raconte
eux ils sont suspendus par leur queue et
donc finalement il se balance ils sont
ensemble et finalement il règle leurs
problèmes de cette façon-là respectueux
je dirais que le résultat c'est le rêve
éveillait ce sont les personnes qui
ont pas obligation de dormir pour
raconter leur rêve Lucas scandale est le
premier artiste invité au musée après
l'exposition ciel et terre du peintre
Grataloup qui a comptabilisé plus de 150
visiteurs par mois le fonctionnement il
est très simple c'est que nous allons
faire deux expositions par an donc une
nécessairement sur le peintre Grataloup
autour d'une thématique spécifique et
puis deuxième où nous aurons justement
un artiste invité l'artiste s'est lancé
le pari d'illustrer l'ensemble des
Fables de La Fontaine il en a déjà peint
plus de la moitié 90 fables restent
encore à réaliser
[Musique]